jean-marc dans l'instant il y aura
également l' enquête parce qu'on va
faire un crime spéciale il ya eu il ya
eu il ya eu vraiment quelque chose
d'horrible qui s'est passé sur l'est de
ramallah gré elle s'est fait attaqué à
l'entrée des beats et le coupable est là
jeudi le coupable est parmi nous il est
parmi vous il est parmi eux
le coupable est là et le coupable on va
le trouver et quand on retrouvera le
coupable
il va passer un sale quart d'heure
puisque pour lui ça va chier des bulles
carré d'ailleurs ce que je propose c'est
bertrand
oui vous rester avec moi pour cette
enquête oui oui vous ne soupçonnez aussi
je soupçonne tout le monde donc et vous
plus que les autres
petit malotru loustics misner suite
jean-marc vous savez que je regarde
crime tous les lundis soirs crime qui a
cartonné d'ailleurs lundi soir près de
800 mille téléspectateurs
aujourd'hui enora malagré
jean-marc enora malagré s'est fait
attaquer demandé huit lâchement nous
avons les images à une personne déguisée
en poule elle et pas n'importe quelle
poule une poule géante ici une poule
c'est vicieux et une poule qui pond
excusez moi comme un oeuf
oui qui s'y passe mais comment la
liaison effet c'était une poule à une
taille normale
c'est possible et n'aura quissac à
qu'elle mène regardez les images
récital à démarrer
je vais trouver je vais te massacrer je
vais te des plumes et c'est parti je
vais démasquer le poulet de ruf
qui a attaqué enora malagré c'est le
crime du jour vous avez vu que je livre
des sushis aussi ça c'est vrai qu'il
évalue à les regarder les airs et nos
racines quand on la voit comme ça de dos
on dirait un enfant de huit ans
alors m jean-marc je crois que vos
équipes ont mené l'enquêté que vous avez
reçu des indices sur le téléphone oui
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
l'époque magie avec enora jean-marc vous
demandez vous devez demander à une
raquette ou face à compliments à chaque
fois si elle veut des indices d'accord
puisque la personne le coupable est ici
le coupable
j'ai pas peur de le dire et tu es sahel
a eu des [ __ ]
on peut rigoler avec tout sauf la
justice est vrai bien alors il vous
voulez un indécis où la première à 10
vous demandez à jean marc faut savoir
qui vous a fait ça vous devez dû faire
un très beau compliment
jean-marc vous avez deux des dents
magnifique et rappelé que ce soir à
22h40 et bien il ya les missions que
toute la france est à temps moi on va
voir messi face à france 22h45 présenté
par l'excellent 22h15 22h45 il brasse et
100 milliards
premier indice alors c'est vous
difficile eh oui oui je poursuis enora
nos équipes ont travaillé longtemps très
longtemps
depuis cet après midi et elles ont un
premier indice à vous révéler ce soir
concernant ce crime qui a été commis
enora jean-marc le ou la coupable
oui à plus de 49 ans le ou la plus de
quarante neuf ans le ou la plus 40
hommes en forme une bonne équipe tous
les deux limites
alors certes le coupable c'est où
bertrand chamerois nom des gens pour
lever bertrand chamerois on peut enlever
qu'à mi combat mais non mais là on est
sur du jour ni du titre i ou de là vers
des zones où il est cagoulé ou éric hély
elle est trop gentil sympa l'histoire la
galoche des câlins avec un an elle a 25
ans il avait moins de 49
bah oui évidemment mais c'est vrai qu'un
gros mystère donc rester discret mais
évidemment elle à moins évidemment là -
oui ça foutez vous de mac os 9 février
oui tous les cas très bien alors donc
enora et nohra le coupable c'est où
jean-michel ont-ils riz ou jason ou
c'est tout mais on a d'autres personnes
âgées
rigole est-ce que moulins deuxième
indice ballon est très gentil avec
jean-marc jean marc morandini vous
m'avez manqué vous m'avez manqué je
manquais d'un ami comme vous oui si
méchant que moi d'accord c'est pas mal
il reste jean michel thierry gilles et
isabelle non non je suis arrivé à 18h
mois
du coup
jean-marc le boulot j'ai maghrébine
menora oui jean marc cet indice va vous
faire avancer énormément dans cette
enquête
ok ce crime a été commis par un homme
donc c'est gilles jehan visuels ou tirer
est ce que vous avez une idée alors
jean-michel n'est pas vraiment un homme
donc c'est entre city et 90 g alors moi
j'ai une vague idée je sais que verdez
est arrivé à un moment où ça c'est pas
très bien mais alors est ce qu'on peut
avoir le costume de la poule grande pour
mener le même temps le nez le même
effectivement ça passe là on peut longer
on peut loger ah oui on peut loger
lenglen vous n'avez pas tort j'hésite
entre morrow et verdès dans ce cas alors
que je vais vous donner à des rousses
des petites gens là vous donnez à
dernière à 10 hockey qui va vous
éclairer cette fois vraiment jean-marc
cette forme et vinci chez vont vous
menez l'anc est bien sûr j'aime chez
vous un avis sur votre écran voilà
j'aime tous vos roues verdez donc morrow
verdez le coupable est généralement
assis à la droite de cyril alors c'est
alors l'hôtel a rien compris à l'autre à
l'école ça et là il s'appelle joyeux à
la droite de sidney
j'étais moi je suis gauchère donc les
pleins c'est à dire que si c'était moi
qui l'ont été là mais la salle à droite
de série doc sommes pas là c'est parce
que c'est pas moi c'est que c'est pas
moi c'est pas moi j'ai trouvé qui sait
le popeck du pauvre thierry moreau pact
arim aux attentes a sonné ça peut être
tout le monde à la vérification en
images
si thierry moreau si je perds et j'ai
encore des oeufs c'est vous découvrez la
taupe pouvez vous venger
si vous vous trompez vous aurez droit à
une deuxième qui au nom non j'ai
l'émission de jean-marc je peux pas je
saute aux yeux c'est pas mal oui
jacques était pas ça ne dérangera pas
fait pour d'autres le père de la
musicienne a quand même
apparemment la vallée une touche sexy
aulas quand même une personne qui décède
sur le bateau mais parfois trouvé
regardez qui a commis ce crime horrible
salut et l'eau salubre paul salut ma
cocotte saint trond 2 noeuds
non
je crois et c'est jean-michel parce que
je ne connaissais pas de coupable
thierry saloperies pourquoi êtes-vous
vus ça j'aime bien casser des oeufs on
casse fait pas d'omelette sans casser
les oeufs puis c'est ma cocotte un peu
et je savais en posant cette question
que vous savez qu'à un moment le citoyen
à la séquence était bien failli
s'arrêter à il est non je lisais sur le
gard et voilà et là c'est la sortie de
route